hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast lab sustainability keeping the
planet and your wallet green in Judea
rourke of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by eppendorf eppendorf is a
leading life science companies that
develops and sells instruments
consumables and services for liquid
sample and fell handling performed in
laboratories around the globe for more
information please visit eppendorf com
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window for submit your
problem through the Greens Rene button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Daniela Moreno product
manager of ult freezers and New
Brunswick shakers at eppendorf North
America I will now turn it over to
daniella for her presentation Thank You
duty for the introduction and thank you
everyone for joining me on today's
webinar with a focus on sustainability
solutions for the lab as technology
advances and globalization develops our
way of life has become more dependent on
energy sources to power our everyday
activities the energy we use in our
everyday life generates the majority of
greenhouse gases in the form of co2
emissions which is responsible for
increasing our carbon footprint co2
emissions have awareness backs on our
atmosphere resulting in environmental
changes that may become detrimental to
human life in the future ironically the
same lab that we are studying the
effects of co2 in our atmosphere or the
lab that is looking for the cure for
cancer to improve human living
conditions is also consuming the most
energy a fifth of the laboratory setting
has many items that are consumed on a
regular basis from energy to lab where
such as plastic tube completes many of
us do not realize there is room for
significant improvement in our daily or
annual processes to reduce consumption
in the lab and offer more sustainable
solution on University campuses today
laboratory space takes up about a
quarter of the campus however these labs
are responsible for consuming about half
of the total energy today's webinar is
going to focus on the general products
that can be found in the lab and how we
can choose maintain and dispose of these
instruments while reducing costs waste
and energy consumption our overall goal
is to greet to decrease our carbon
footprint educate researchers and
everyone who is a part of our global
community about sustainable solutions
and to offer peace of mind for future
generations there are many opportunities
to reduce our carbon footprint rails
still optimizing science which is what
we will talk about today the first
product we are going to address our fume
hoods few pledges are one of the most
important safety features to be found at
a lab however they consume more energy
than anything else they're responsible
for consuming about three to three and
half times the amount of energy needed
to run the average American household
energy is consumed at a fan motor to
close the air through the front of the
hood and out of the sack energy is also
consumed in order to keep cool humidify
or dehiscence modified that volume of
air that is being discharged into the
atmosphere if the sash is left open a
fume hood can start to cause upwards of
five thousand dollars a year to operate
so what can we do the reducing energy
consumption here what importance an easy
thing to do is to shut the fume hood
stash shutting the sash will reduce the
volume of air being drawn through the
hood
even on single speed drive hoods next
reducing obstructions in the fume hood
improve the efficiency by allowing
adequate air flow across the working
surface with minimum turbulence it is
also important to keep fume hoods clear
of unnecessary items that can block
ventilation next when purchasing new
equipment Explorer efficient options
some fume hoods are designed to be
energy-efficient without additional
measures such as ductless fume hoods and
high-performance team hood that operate
at lower phase velocities with newer
variable speed drive hoods the air
volume can be reduced from sixty to
eighty percent when the sashes clothes
which results in incredible energy
savings second to fume hoods ultra-low
temperature freezers or DLP freezers are
the second biggest energy suckers in the
lab on average a typical upgrade
ultra-low temperature freezer consumes
about point eight five kilowatt hours
per day per cubic foot in a laboratory
setting as most upright freezers aren't
averaged about 25 cubic feet this means
they are consuming about 21.25 kilowatt
hours per day this is about the same
energy needed to run the average
American household on average every lab
has between two and three you will see
freezers here in the US to give some
perspective there is an estimated 58,000
you will cease to be found in California
alone when crunching the numbers this
means that you will see is in California
alone consume 1.2 million kilowatt hours
per day which adds up to 937 tons of co2
emissions that are reporting into our
atmosphere if we take anything away from
these numbers it should be that there is
a significant room for improvement to
have a more sustainable approach for
long-term sample storage and ultra-low
temperature freezers
so what can we do here to make efforts
towards efficient solutions when
purchasing new freezers it's important
to get information on the energy
consumption of that freezer also look
for products that have low heat output
this will indirectly reduce the energy
consumption by reducing the size AC unit
needed to cool down the ambient
temperature where the freezers are
located also when comparing these
specifications it is important to know
that you are not comparing apples to
apples between different manufacturers
always ask about how the efficiencies
specifications were achieved it is also
important to inquire about performance
as well considering very precious
samples are continuously being stored in
these ultralow freezers now the most
efficient you will see would be the you
will see that's not even plugged in but
what good would that be we need to also
make sure it holds the temperature that
we need recovers the temperature that we
need a key to our sample space there is
no room for compromising performance as
a community we are working towards a
standard for testing however right now
the best way to compare performance of a
ult is by comparing the pulldown times
from ambient temperature this is the
most stressful activity of an ultra low
that it has to perform and is the most
standardized way to compare various
models high quality materials and design
are also very important many mates see
in ultra low as of a box that gets cold
but the materials particularly the outer
door gasket is very important to take
notice to for efficiency performance and
product longevity the outer door gasket
on any ult is the most vulnerable place
on the freezer to these cold air often
ice buildup on these gaskets as ice
buildup the integrity of your seal
decreases resulting in an increase in
cold air loss this increases the
compressors running and decreases the
performance and efficiency
therefore it is additionally recommended
to clear ice buildup on the seals and
inspect all seals and gaskets routinely
this leper leads us to routine
maintenance similar to your car and how
you need to regularly get oil changes an
ultra-low needs some maintenance to run
efficiently over the lifetime of a ult
freezers the energy consumption required
to run the system will increase these
efforts will keep your freezer running
optimally check gaskets and rubber seals
around the freezer door and clear away
any ice build up with a soft cloth or
rubber ice scraper be cautious to avoid
damaging rubber seals next clean the
filter that protects the condenser coils
often for uprights this will be found on
the bottom of the freezer and this will
allow for proper air circulation and
cooling always performed annual
cleanouts defrosting and inventory
checks once ice buildup gets about
three-eighths of an inch and see the
freezer to do a manual defrost during
this process evaluate what samples are
being stored within the freezer it is
okay to get rid of samples especially
those which are not labeled may be
expired or belong to researchers who no
longer work there this will lead room
for other samples and make them easier
to find essentially also reducing the
time before you need to purchase another
freezer for sample storage take notice
to your freezers performance over time
there are some signs to look for such as
when a freezer have a pattern of being
slow to recover or can I keep
temperature temperature uniformity
within the chamber is outside the
manufacturer's specifications when you
hear the compressor running constantly
this is indicative that the compressor
isn't running over time when you feel a
lot of heat coming off of the freezer or
the ambient temperature of the room is
in
using and also when there are signs of
heavy frost affecting the ability of the
door to have a good seal these are all
signs that indicate that it might be
time to maintain or have a check of your
freezer to make sure that it's really
running under optimal conditions for
optimal efficiency being green matters
most when you don't notice it now it may
be obvious that the very large equipment
in the lab are the products that consume
the most energy such as our fume hoods
or ultra-low temperature freezers but
what about all the other items in the
lab that are plugged in or consumed
everything from microcentrifuge is to
thermal cyclers your people off or
electronic pipettes are consuming energy
and some instances you may not even
realize how much energy they actually
consume starting with some thermal
cyclers thermal cyclers need to be need
to precisely manage high temperatures
across a block to ensure accurate and
reproducible amplification of nucleic
acids also news products run all day
consuming energy at all hours so what
can we do here to make it effort towards
choosing an efficient approach look for
equipment that has shorter run time if
you are able to reduce a PCR rum from
four hours to three hours you are now
eliminating one hour of energy needed to
control the temperature on the block
essentially saving energy there are a
few technologies available that provide
faster one x also look for equipment
that has a standby mode to reduce energy
consumption when the product is not a
nice but may need to be turned on and
warmed up that day also if you need to
run multiple blocks check for the
capability to hook up to a satellite
system this allows you to use just one
control center to manage multiple cycler
blocks the less control Tanner's or
centers you use the less energy need to
manage the blocks also reducing overall
energy consumption additionally
something to think about is if there's a
technology that supports you using less
reagents local allows you to use the
smaller sample size without having to
worry about evaporation the smaller the
sample size the left free agency used
directly correlating to waste during pcr
the grass we have here shows the power
consumption of a typical PCR run for
various different models of thermal
cyclers that are available to
researchers today where is the kilowatt
hour youth it seems much lower than
those of a ult freezer or fume hood
these numbers can really add up quickly
especially when multiple runs are done
in a day and when there are multiple PCR
machines there are usually about two
cyclers / lab and about three runs per
day per cycler if you choose the right
cycler you can reduce your energy
consumption significantly now here we
have we can see that we have a few
different manufacturers have the options
of a standby mode this allows the
machine to be plugged in but consumed
significantly less energy while also
being ready to be warmed up quickly this
is a great feature to look for when
purchasing a new cycler however be aware
that many of the units are Chavez
standby mode are still using energy and
some significantly more than others
another recommendation would be actually
unplug all equipment when not in use to
avoid energy consumption while machine
or is assumedly turned off
refrigerated centrifuges are staple in
any lab setting often there is a
one-to-one ratio of refrigerated micra
centrifuges personnel in the lab so what
can we do here to improve efficiency and
sustainability when looking for a new
scent refuse look for programmability
options for cooling oftentimes
researchers may turn on a refrigerated
centrifuge to cool overnight so that
when they get in the morning the
centrifuge with a descent temperature
usually around 4 degrees Celsius and
they can start working as you can
imagine this process concerns can
consume a lot of energy there are
technologies out there that allow you to
program your centrifuge similar to your
coffee maker to turn on and start
cooling at a particular time on a
particular day these programmability
features can save up to any eighty
percent of energy consumption which is a
huge savings you can also look for
centrifuges that have faster pulldown
time to set temperature the quicker as
interviews can pull down to the
temperature the less energy needs to
consume for instance if the
refrigeration system needs to take 40
minutes to get dad to a 4 degrees set
temperature versus eight minutes you're
saving 32 minutes of the compressors
running time essentially reducing your
overall energy consumption similarly to
the PCR machine some centrifuges may
also have the capability of being put
into a standby mode or even
automatically turn off after hours of
non use these features alone can result
in a 50-percent energy savings per
centrifuge which brings us to our next
point making sure the centrifuge just
like any other products is made of
quality materials and construction now
there are many different types of
centrifuges on the market all made with
a variety of purposes however for center
to spin at high g-forces or spin
hazardous materials it is a
misconception that the product lifetime
of a centrifuge the six months to two
years your centrifuge should last much
longer than that anywhere from at least
five to seven years or maybe even longer
this will significantly reduce waste we
see from the lab additionally the
construction of the accessories such as
the rotors can also open an opportunity
to have a more sustainable lab many
rotors now are made to be lighter which
helps reduce the energy needed from the
centrifuge to spin that rotor and your
samples at such high speeds also many
rotors are also made to be one hundred
percent recyclable consumables or
plastic ware found in the lab such as
two plates flasks speakers and many
others are used in everyday lab settings
these items are generally used once and
thrown away for reasons such as
contamination and convenience therefore
there are a few small things we can do
to make significant strides towards our
sustainable lab choose products that are
properly marked with codes to be
recycled if they are not marked you
cannot recycle them and reduce a
significant amount of waste choose
products that do not use harmful toxins
in the manufacturing process not only is
this making a conscious effort to choose
a sustainable product but these toxins
can also contaminate your sample skewing
your results and downstream applications
this will also lead to excessive waste
of consumables and samples many times we
often use a 15 or 50 ml tube to store
samples however many times you're not
actually putting that much volume into
our tube look for tubes of smaller size
to store your samples and if possible
this reduces the amount of class
waste but also reduce the amount of
space needed to store these tubes if you
are putting these into an ultra-low
temperature freezer for long-term
storage you can store almost double the
amount of samples if you choose a
smaller vessel also we do not need 208
these plastic you can still choose to
use glass for applications such as cell
Bros and flask which will also
significantly reduce waste automation
liquid handlers are more commonly being
used for sample preparation using liquid
handling automation has the utmost
precision and accuracy which optimizes
the remaining volumes and any loud
vessels eliminating waste also with the
precision and accuracy bc Whitney
systems we are able to use less reagents
and smaller samples which reduced ways
as well additionally due to the
programmability you can choose when tips
are disposed of this plus the ability to
reload your tips can reduce plastic
waste in these systems by up to forty
percent
reducing water waste is also a big topic
of discussion when striving for a
sustainable lab instruments such as he
blocks or dry incubation systems
eliminate the need for water and also
reduce the energy needed to heat or cool
your samples he cheated blocks also
reduces the amount of energy needed to
keep your blocks upset direct heat
technology found in co2 incubators now
offer a more sustainable alternatives to
water jacketed systems which required a
significant amount of water to the brown
the incubator for temperature management
so just a few small things here that can
reduce water waste whereas the effects
are not always tangible and it's hard
for some to justify making changes to
the daily routine of purchasing or
maintaining equipment the biotechnology
industry has now recognized its role in
this global initiative and has focused
on improving laboratory products to
reduce energy consumption without
depriving functionality or
reproducibility so in summary we have a
ton of tips to help reach our goal of
having a sustainable lab in review when
choosing new lab equipments remember to
look at the energy consumption of that
product think about if it is a product
that is used essentially 24 hours a day
or if it as a product that is used
bradical e as instruments used more
often will offer the biggest value in
reducing energy consumption are there
any special features such as
programmability or a standby mode that
will additionally help in the efforts to
reduce energy consumption while the
products are plugged in make sure you
also choose a quality product that will
last and in doing so make sure no
specifications are compromised by
choosing an efficient design science
still needs to be accurate and
reproducible and choosing a quality
product will help with the
efforts additionally make sure you are
covered by warranty especially on parts
of your equipment that may affect the
efficiency of that product maintaining
lab equipment properly ensures
efficiency and product longevity this
comes back to the statement of choosing
quality products for the labs that will
last a long time but it may have another
life in another lab setting make sure
everyone is educated on the best
practices for maintaining the products
in the lab and knowing when to schedule
a service or preventive maintenance
lastly properly disposing or recycling
your products at the end of their life
in a particular lab setting can
significantly reduce waste make sure
products are properly marked for easy
recycling and ask facilities or your
local staff representative about
recycling programs which will help in
the removal recycle and disposal of old
or damaged products reducing energy
consumption of the products in the lab
to screen in your wallet to bike using
efficient lab equipment and properly
maintaining current lab equipment you
will significantly reduce our carbon
footprint but also reduce the amounts of
money spent on your electric bill you
can save thousands per lab by making
just these small efforts reducing energy
consumption saves money saves our planet
and face our quality of life for us
today and for future generations
lastly education is key we are always
learning new ways to make significant
improvements to our everyday routines
many manufacturers of lab equipment
University groups and researchers keep
finding new ways to keep our blue planet
green while keeping degree in your
pocket please feel free to reach out or
ask questions or make comments at this
time I would like to thank you all for
joining me on this portion of the
presentation thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I'd like to remind our audience
how to submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can also
the slides are available for download in
a PDF version on the lower left of your
screen okay question is what are your
thoughts on keeping your ult freezer at
minus 70 degrees versus minus 80 degrees
that's a very good question many are
moving towards keeping their freezer at
minus 70 vs minus 80 and we do see
significant reductions in energy
consumption at running our freezers at
these temperatures however it is
important to consider the biologics that
are being put inside these freezers
minus 70 might not be a suitable
temperature for some samples and so we
don't want to compromise the integrity
of our samples so we just need to choose
wisely on when we set certain freezers
at certain temperatures rate is it more
efficient to purchase the largest
capacity ult available overall large
freezers we will have a lower energy
consumption per cubic foot however when
it comes to
security and backing up a freezer often
if you pick the largest trees are
available it may be difficult to back up
that freezer when necessary so again it
really is a balance of choosing an
efficient design but without
compromising the security of your
freezer setup okay if there are no more
questions I would once again like to
shank daniela moreno for her
presentation do you have any final
comments cannula at this time I would
just like to thank everyone for their
time today for additional information
please feel free to review this webinar
which is available via PDF feel free to
visit our website or contact myself or
your local sales representative for more
information I would also like to thank
our sponsor eppendorf for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through March seventeen to
twenty sixteen you will receive an email
from lamb roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to Ford that announcement to
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event do you next time
goodbye